>>> WELCOME BACK.
NOW, THE MAYOR OF KABUL SAYS HE
STILL BELIEVES IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PRINCIPLES THAT FIT AFGHANISTAN,
EVEN AFTER THE TALIBAN OVERRAN
THE GOVERNMENT.
THE MAYOR SAYS HE'S BEEN ALLOWED
TO KEEP HIS JOB.
MAYOR MOHOMMAD JOINS ME NOW FROM
SKYPE FROM THE CAPITOL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
I GUESS THE QUESTION IS ARE YOU
STILL THE MAYOR OF KABUL?
WE HEARD REPORTS THAT THERE WAS
A PARALLEL MAYOR PUT IN PLACE BY
THE TALIBAN.
>> NO, ACTUALLY HE'S NOT A
PARALLEL MAYOR.
HE'S IN CHARGE OF THE COMMISSION
THAT OVERSEES ALL MAYORS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
AND HE'S WORKING FROM THE
MUNICIPALITY WITH ME THERE.
BUT HE'S IN CHARGE OF THE
COMMISSION, AND I'M STILL AS OF
THIS AFTERNOON WHEN I LEFT MY
OFFICE, I WAS STILL THE MAYOR.
>> OKAY.
SO, THIS IS WHERE IT BECOMES
INTERESTING BECAUSE I THINK YOU
CAN GIVE US A LITTLE BIT OF AN
IDEA OF THE LEADERSHIP STRUCTURE
RIGHT NOW.
YOU WERE APPOINTED BY ASHRAF
GHANI.
HE FLED THE COUNTRY.
I KNOW THAT YOU'VE SAID BEFORE
THAT YOU WERE CALLED TO GO BACK
TO WORK TO CONTINUE YOUR
SERVICE.
WHO ARE YOU TAKING ORDERS FROM
NOW?
ARE YOU NOW WORKING ESSENTIALLY
FOR THE TALIBAN?
>> ACTUALLY I'M WORKING FOR THE
PEOPLE OF KABUL.
WE ARE PROVIDING SERVICE.
THERE IS NO GOVERNMENT.
AND ONE OF MY DUTIES IS TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE.
AND WHEN EVERYBODY FLED THE
COUNTRY, AND THOSE PUNDITS,
ESPECIALLY THOSE AFGHANS WHO
CALL THEMSELVES PUNDITS CRYING
CROCODILE TEARS AND SAY THAT WE
BETRAYED OUR PRINCIPLES AND
DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES, HAD I
LEFT KABUL LIKE OTHERS DID AND I
HAD I LEFT MY DUTY, WHAT WOULD
THAT BE CALLED?
I THINK THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
TREASON.
SO, I'M SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
KABUL.
I'M PROVIDING THE SERVICES THAT
THEY BADDELY NEED.
AND THE GOVERNMENT OF KABUL HAD
COLLAPSED, WHAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED TO 6 MILLION PEOPLE.
WE SHOULD ASK QUESTION.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND LOOK, YOU ARE SITTING IN THE
ECONOMIC POWER HOUSE OF THE
COUNTRY, SO IT'S A VITAL CITY.
YOU HAVE RAN FOR PRESIDENT
BEFORE.
YOU UNDERSTAND THE POLITICS IN
THE COUNTRY QUITE EXTENSIVELY
I'M SURE.
BUT COULD YOU GIVE US AN
UNDERSTANDING -- ARE YOU TAKING
ORDERS FROM ANY SPECIFIC PERSON
OR SOMEONE WITHIN THE TALIBAN?
YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE SERVING THE
PEOPLE OF AFGHANISTAN RIGHT NOW.
ARE YOU JUST GOING ON ALONG WITH
WHAT YOU HAD PUT IN PLACE PRIOR
TO THE TALIBAN TAKEOVER?
OR DO YOU HAVE A NEW SET OF
ORDERS AND MANDATES THAT YOU
HAVE TO ADHERE TO?
>> THE ORDERS THAT ARE BEING
ISSUED BY THE TALIBAN
LEADERSHIP, IT'S NOT BEING
ORDERED BY A GOVERNMENT THAT IS
INFORMED YET.
NO GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN FORMED.
MOST OF THOSE ORDERS ARE
SECURITY ORIENTED.
AND WHAT I'M DOING IS PROVIDING
SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE OF THIS
CITY.
SO, WE ARE DOING WHAT WE WERE
DOING BEFORE.
AND AS IT IS DICTATED BY THE
NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE, THERE ARE
NO ORDERS THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTED TOWARDS THE
MUNICIPALITY FOR THE TALIBAN
BECAUSE THERE'S NO GOVERNMENT
YET.
AND WHEN THAT IS FORMED, THEN WE
WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT KIND OF
GOVERNMENT.
I HOPE THAT IT'S AN INCLUSIVE
I HOPE THE TALIBAN ARE TALKING
TO PEOPLE LIKE US WHO BELIEVE IN
QUADRATIC PRINCIPLES, NOT TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE WAR LORDS AND
DRUG LORDS AND GRABBERS, LAND
GRABBERS, WHO ARE TRYING TO
RESUSCITATE THEMSELVES.
THEY RAN AWAY AND NOW THEY WANT
TO COME BACK.
>> SO, COULD YOU GIVE ME AN IDEA
OF THE CONVERSATIONS WITH
TALIBAN OFFICIALS?
WHAT ARE THEY SPEAKING TO YOU
ABOUT?
AND WHAT ARE YOU RELAYING BACK
TO THEM?
>> TO BE VERY HONEST AND VERY
ACCURATE, THEY TOOK OVER KABUL.
THEY HAVE VERY LITTLE EXPERIENCE
IN RUNNING A GOVERNMENT.
THEY HAVE NO EXPERTISE IN
RUNNING A GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE IN CHARGE.
THEY'RE IN POWER.
BUT THEY NEED TO HAVE A
FUNCTIONING GOVERNMENT THAT HAS
EXPERTS AND ADMINISTRATIVE AND
ECONOMIC AND TECHNICAL KNOW-HOW
THAT WILL RUN VARIOUS BRANCHES
OF THE GOVERNMENT.
AND WE HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE WHAT
KIND OF PEOPLE THEY WILL PUT IN
THE GOVERNMENT.
THAT WILL BE THE LITMUS TEST.
AND WHAT I DID IN STAYING IN
KABUL, I HAVE THROWN THE BALL IN
THEIR COURT.
TELL THEM THAT, LOOK, WE ARE
HERE, AND IF YOU WANT AN
INCLUSIVE GOVERNMENT, YOU BETTER
PROVE IT BY BRINGING THE RIGHT
PEOPLE, NOT THE SAME WAR LORDS
AND TURN COATS WHO WANT TO COME
BACK AND LOOT MORE OF THE FIGHT
THEY ALREADY HAVE LOOTED.
>> IN TERMS OF SERVING THE
PEOPLE IN AFGHANISTAN, THE
PEOPLE IN KABUL, WE'VE HEARD
FROM NUMEROUS PEOPLE THAT THE
BANKS HAVE BEEN CLOSED.
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO DRAW
MONEY.
AND THIS IS OBVIOUSLY PUT PEOPLE
IN A VERY SORT OF DIFFICULT
SITUATION.
GIVE ME AN UPDATE ON WHEN THE
BANKS ARE GOING TO BE OPENING UP
AND WHETHER YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT
A RUN ON THE BANKS AND WHAT THAT
WOULD MEAN FOR FINANCIAL
STABILITY.
>> THERE ARE MANY FACTORS THAT
THE BANKS ARE SLOW TO OPEN.
NATURALLY IT'S VERY EASY TO SHUT
THEM DOWN, BUT IT TAKES A WHILE
TO OPEN THEM BACK BECAUSE THE
CENTRAL BANK HAS FROZEN ABROAD
BY THE UNITED STATES AND BY
OTHER INSTITUTIONS.
THEREFORE, THE CONNECTION OF THE
LOCAL BANKS, CENTRAL BANK AND
THE CASH FLOW AND THE CHAIN THAT
EXISTS HAS TO BE REVAMPED AND
HAS TO BE REVITALIZED BEFORE THE
BANKS CAN OPEN TOTALLY.
SOME BANKS OPEN VERY SLOWLY, AND
MANY EXCHANGES ARE OPEN RIGHT
NOW.
BUT THE FULL FUNCTIONING BANKS
ARE NOT THERE YET.
>> SO, WHERE DOES THIS LEAVE
AVERAGE PEOPLE THAT HAVE RUN OUT
OF MONEY ESSENTIALLY?
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT THEM?
>> YES, VERY MUCH SO.
THIS IS A VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
ECONOMY IS THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
THAT THE NEW GOVERNMENT HAS TO
DEAL WITH.
OUR REVENUES, OUR RELATIONS WITH
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY, OUR
LOANS, OUR AID MONEY, THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WERE MADE
INTO THE AFGHAN FUND THAT WAS
FOR RECONSTRUCTION OF
AFGHANISTAN, THESE ARE ALL
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE TO GRAPPLE
WITH AND WE HAVE TO BE A
GOVERNMENT THAT HAS TO
UNDERSTAND THOSE THINGS AND HAS
TO ABIDE BY INTERNATIONAL
LAURELS TO TAP INTO THOSE
RESOURCES AGAIN.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU SAY THAT YOU
WANT AN INCLUSIVE GOVERNMENT,
AND YOU SAY YOU STAYED BEHIND.
ASHRAF GHANI SAID HE FLED
BECAUSE HE FEARED HE WAS GOING
TO BE HANGED.
DOES THIS MEAN YOU WANT TO BE
PART OF THIS GOVERNMENT?
ARE YOU PLANNING FOR RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT AGAIN?
DO YOU THINK THE TALIBAN IS
GOING TO TAKE A DEMOCRATIC
APPROACH.
YOU STILL BELIEVE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
THE TALIBAN HAS BEEN VERY
INTERESTING TO WATCH IN TERMS OF
THE MESSAGING AND HOW THEY WANT
TO HANDLE THE FUTURE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT'S GOING
TO LOOK LIKE?
>> YOU SEE, I AM GIVING THEM THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT RIGHT NOW.
EVERY FEW DECADES, THE PEOPLE OF
AFGHANISTAN, AFTER EVERY TURMOIL
HAVE RUN AWAY FROM THIS COUNTRY.
I WAS ONE IN THE SOVIET INVASION
AND I SAW WHAT HAPPENED TO THIS
COUNTRY.
I DON'T WANT TO CREATE THE SAME
MISTAKE TO GIVE THE EXTREMISTS
AN EXCUSE THAT THERE'S NOBODY
ELSE BUT THEM TO RUN THE
COUNTRY.
THEREFORE THIS IS A DOUBLE EDGED
SWORD.
WHILE PEOPLE ARE AFRAID FOR
THEIR LIVES, OTHERS ARE HERE TO
FULFILL THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND OF COURSE THE FORMATION FOR
THE NEW GOVERNMENT, RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT, THESE ARE ALL FUTURE
THINGS THAT THE BEHAVIOR OF THE
TALIBAN, THE FORMATION OF A NEW
GOVERNMENT, THE CREATION OF THE
NEW CONSTITUTION AND ALL THE
OTHER THINGS ARE HANGING, AND WE
HAVE TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS AND
THEN MAKE THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF
WHAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO DO.
>> OKAY.
SO, 31st OF AUGUST.
THAT'S THE DEADLINE.
IN THE MEANTIME, ISIS-K THREATS
TO THE U.S. IS VERY REAL.
THEY'VE POTENTIALLY THREATENED
TO, YOU KNOW, BOMB AND ATTACK
CROWDS AROUND THE AIRPORT.
YOU'RE CURRENTLY TAKING DOWN THE
CONCRETE WALLS AND STRUCTURES
THAT WERE USED FOR PROTECTION.
ISIS-K HAS TARGETED KABUL IN THE
PAST.
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT THIS
THREAT?
DO YOU THINK THAT THIS IS A
POSSIBILITY WHEN A FOREIGN
FORCES ACTUALLY FINALLY LEAVE
THE COUNTRY?
>> WELL, ACTUALLY, THE THREAT IS
ALWAYS THERE IN A COUNTRY THAT
HAS BEEN AT WAR FOR 40 YEARS.
THERE ARE MANY ELEMENTS THAT
COULD THREATEN THE VERY, VERY
STRENUOUS SITUATION THAT ALREADY
WE ARE IN.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WE HAVE TO
CREATE LAW AND ORDER.
WE HAVE TO CREATE THE SEMBLANCE
OF NORMALCY.
I WAS REMOVING THESE OBSTACLES
AND THESE WALLS EVEN BEFORE THE
TALIBAN CAME TO POWER.
AND NOW WE HAVE SPEEDED UP THIS
THING BECAUSE THEY ALSO WANT
THESE THINGS TO BE REMOVED.
AND THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SECURITY SO THAT PEOPLE
CAN LIVE A NORMAL LIFE.
WHEN THE WAR IS OVER, THEN THE
NORMAL LIFE HAS TO START.
AND THESE THINGS ARE PART OF
NORMAL LIFE.
OPEN STREETS, OPEN AVENUES, OPEN
CITY.
SO PEOPLE CAN BREATHE AND THE
ECONOMY CAN BREATHE AND
EVERYTHING WILL COME BACK TO
NORMAL.
WE HAVE TO DO THIS FOR THE
PEOPLE.
WE OWE IT TO THE PEOPLE BECAUSE
SEVERAL GENERATIONS OF THESE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN LIVING IN TEA
WALLS AND BEHIND CONCRETE WALLS
AND THE GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
OPERATING IN A VERY, VERY
UNDESIRABLE SITUATION FOR THE
PAST FEW DECADES.
>> MAYOR